avec le chef yannick alléno chef
triplement étoilé à la tête de 18
établissements dans le monde dont le
doyen à paris bon soir yannick alléno
merci beaucoup d'être avec nous en
direct sur arte france partie les
signataires de cette tribune parue chez
nos confrères du figaro
que demandez-vous précisément emmanuel
macron alors on ne demande rien aux
présidents on propose on propose au
président c'est à dire que je pense que
le temps est venu de dar été de réclamer
et de se prendre en main je pense que le
et nous pensons d'ailleurs que la
restauration peut s'organiser pour
commencer à accueillir le public dans
des règles de sécurité et pour notre
personnel et pour lui des clients
optimum donc ça veut dire qu'il faut que
l'on réfléchisse nos espaces autrement
nos procédures d'accueil et de remettre
gentiment la vie en route parce que
dépend de nous plein de fournisseurs
plein de producteurs des vignerons et
tout et on n'a pas envie d'attendre que
le gouvernement nous dise devront
démarrer au mois de septembre au mois
d'octobre j'en sais rien donc on a envie
de proposer de faire de faire en sorte
que deux restaurants revivent petit à
petit en réunion ii question de réouvrir
100% c'est sûr mais en tout cas que les
flammèches de nos fourneaux commença à
est un seul est alors vous avez
justement pour cela envoyer plusieurs
solutions en hier soir au gouvernement
pour permettre cette réouverture
expliquez-nous un petit peu parce que
c'est vrai qu'on a du mal à imaginer la
compatibilité entre cette distanciation
sociale les gestes barrières et
l'activité d'un restaurant ou
nécessairement il y a forcément dû
contacter bien sûr alors pour vous
donner un exemple j'ai un restaurant en
corée ce qui m'aide aujourd'hui à
comprendre comment les choses ont évolué
dans des pays qui réagissent
différemment et encore et on a mis tout
un protocole nouveau en place pour
accueillir les clients et on a commencé
à faire 30 couverts aujourd'hui on a
fait 110 par joe donc ça fonctionne
plutôt pas mal donc on a mis en place et
2,7 ou n'ai pas à dire applicables au
restaurant
certains ont des solutions et d'autres
d'autres solutions mais en tout cas je
vous explique ce que nous avons mis en
place en corée à l'aide du gouvernement
coréen des tapis de désinfection c'est à
dire que client arrive il a déjà fait 4
mètres et ses chaussures ont été
désinfectés des boîtes à usage unique ou
dans lequel le client mais son masque
pour aller à table un sas de je dirais
de désinfection de ses mains
les manteaux sont mis sous des films
plastiques de que l'on peut trouver
d'ailleurs dans les pressings c'est les
mêmes choses et ensuite les personnels
aux contacts portent des masques et des
gants et en cuisine nous portons des
visières des toques des gants il ya des
postes des infections à m 2 un maître du
temps qui fait le tour des cuisiniers
pour le pro leur rappeler les bons
gestes et bons gestes barrières mais
vous savez en cuisine on a quand même
l'habitude de cette rigueur puisque
depuis tout le temps désinfectant de
cuisine depuis tout le temps désinfecte
les yeux depuis tout temps on se lave
les mains et l'hygiène est quelque chose
de éminemment déjà ancrée donc il faut
aller plus loin dans ses démarches et de
et on va essayer d'écrire un livre ait
de bonnes pratiques pour commencer à
prouver au gouvernement que nous sommes
capables d'accueillir du public dans de
bonnes conditions et je pense que c'est
important
yannick heulot pardonnez moi parce que
le temps passe malheureusement il ya 17
chefs très prestigieux qui ont signé
cette tribune pour la plupart qui ont ce
qu'on appelle des grands restaurants
mais vous vous exprimez vous y tenez au
nom aussi des autres restaurateurs
peut-être plus modestes est ce que cette
stratégie vous semble mise
pardon appris qu'un pardon à des
restaurants peut-être plus modestes mais
bien sûr je pense que on se le rappeler
tout à l'heure avec alain ducasse
il y aura les bons il y aura les mauvais
les bons doivent qu'il soit petit grand
est immense
étoilé pas étoiles et appliqués en
fonction de l'heure de leur capacité
l'accueil des clients
il y avait stéphane jégo qui a son
bistrot l'ami jean avec nous il est
d'accord avec tout cela je dire il est
hors de question de dire qu'il ya quatre
ans qui ouvre et l'éthique qui restent
fermés c'est impossible d'imaginer ça en
attendant chacun qui décide d'ouvrir
doit être responsable de cette qualité
hygiène et de sécurité de des clients et
du staff
s'il ne peut pas le faire écouter il
faudra attendre un petit peu que les
choses s'améliorent mais je pense qu'il
ya beaucoup beaucoup d'établissements il
ya 120 mille ou cent quatre amis à
l'établissement en france qui seront
capables d'ouvrir gentiment à la
clientèle et qui sont je le rappelle
tous des restaurants de qualité au
collège culinaire de france aider des
gens qui ont l'habitude de faire
attention à tous les détails
il ya vraiment danger de mort pour
plusieurs restaurants parmi justement
ces 17 chefs selon vous réellement mais
bien sûr il va falloir parler d'eux des
loyers il va falloir parler des
assurances udir desquels et les choses
c'est m on le disait le docteur d etat
leur le mettre sous cloche chez truc
décaler les choses c'est mais c'est
mettre sous cloche un problème il ya des
établissements avec avec très peu de
trésorerie qui sont déjà en train de se
poser la question d'autoriser ou pas
maintenant on pense que si on ne fait
rien et que fais pas les choses de façon
quasi de 40% des établissements fermés
qui sont partis effectivement des
fleurons de la gastronomie française
merci à vous et yannick alléno chef
triplement étoilé d'avoir été avec nous
en direct sur arte france